I also want to mention this uh this is
not a story yet not a headline yet but
it will be uh we got an email from uh
the reporters at some reporters at
Rolling Stone and uh my team got an
email from reporters of Rolling Stone
and this is an email from someone named
Nikki McCann Ramirez and uh when I when
they sent me this email I recognized
that name wasn't sure where I recognized
it from and I looked it up and okay sure
enough uh Nikki McCann Ramirez used to
be a shill over at Media Matters and
then she left Media Matters at some
point and now is a shill for Rolling
Stone
so it's like the media matter is
obviously far left activist group
they Rolling Stone brings her over as a
reporter she's now a journalist
here's the here's the email because this
is kind of funny
and this also shows you this is how
these people operate okay
um
at any time like any time you read a a
hit piece about someone a conservative
in one of these corporate media outlets
and it'll always say something like we
reached out to so and so but didn't get
a comment and they put that in there and
then it's supposed to make it look like
oh that person's hiding they don't want
to talk about it you really got them
this time
well if you want to know why there's no
comments
it's because when they reach out
this is what it sounds like here's the
email
my name is Nikki McCann Ramirez and I'm
a politics reporter with rolling stone
we're reaching out because my colleague
EJ Dixon and I are working on a piece
about right-wing influencers
increasingly focused on posting
transphobic content and we're citing Mr
Matt Walsh as an example as we have
noticed he has centered much of his
content around transgender individuals
in the past several years would he like
to provide comment Regarding why he has
made this topic an area of focus and
what initially drew his attention to it
please let us know by tomorrow EOD if Mr
Walsh would like to add any add anything
to our piece that's so generous of you
hey we're about to publish a hit piece
um and there's zero chance of it being
objective or anything and we don't care
about Mr Walsh's perspective in the
least we're going to call him a
transphobe it's an article all about how
he's a transphobic bigot what he likes
to contribute to his own hit piece with
everything going on in the world right
now you could really use a good night's
sleep and that's why you need to check
out Helix mattress Helix has harnessed
years of extensive mattress expertise to
bring their customers a truly elevated
sleep experience they just launched
their new Helix Elite the Helix Elite
collection includes six different
mattress models each tailored for
specific sleep positions and firmness
preferences I've had my Helix for years
now and I absolutely love it night after
night I sleep like a sweet sweet baby
and I want the same for all of you Helix
has a sleep quiz that matches your body
type and preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else go to
helixsleep.com Walsh and take their
two-minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type their flexible payment plans make
it so make it so that a great night's
sleep is never far away for a limited
time Helix is giving you 20 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners you could take advantage
of this amazing offer at helixsleep.com
Walsh with Helix better sleep starts now
I mean never mind the fact that and I
and they haven't published the article
yet but I'm going to assume that they're
not going to put any disclaimer on the
article noting that the journalists
quote unquote involved in this article
um used to work at Media Matters
are far left audio logs
and are on the record personally hating
the people they're reporting on
they're not gonna there's gonna be no
disclaimer no qualifications there that
won't be mentioned
well I did I did offer a response on
Twitter anyway and um I said and this is
you know and this goes in general to any
media outlet that wants to publish a hit
piece on me uh and you know you're
welcome to do it uh I'm always happy for
for all the coverage
if you want me to contribute to it and
you want my comment I'm also happy to
provide comment if you can first answer
my question that I've been asking uh
which is you know if you can provide a
definition of the word woman then I will
give you a comment so pretty simple
that's the trade and that's what I would
say to you Nikki McCann Ramirez just get
uh you know you can email me you can put
it on Twitter you can message it however
you want to do it
send me what your definition of the word
woman and then I'll send you a comment
it's fair trade
we'll see we'll see if they take me up
on the offer hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there